im nordrhein westfälischen duisburg ist
diese brücke seit sage und schreibe vier
jahren gesperrt eigentlich verläuft hier
eine wichtige verkehrsachse für den
stadtteil rheinhausen doch weil die
marode brücke aus sicherheitsgründen
dicht ist ist hier schluss und der
verkehr quält sich jetzt durch die
wohngebiete die duisburger fordern seit
jahren dass endlich etwas passiert dann
ist also eine riesenkatastrophe es ist
schlängelt sich jetzt überall der
verkehr durch durch durch alle möglichen
straßen und groß großer mist also ich
finde dass rabinowitz die brücke ist
über 100 jahre alt und rostet seit
jahrzehnten vor sich hin das problem sie
die genau an der stadtgrenze zwischen
duisburg und moers hat mehr als 20
jahren wissen die kommunen eigentlich
dass man die brücke retten muss können
sich aber nicht auf sanierungs und
neubaupläne einigen die konsequenz 2017
wird sie dann komplett gesperrt ein
verkehrschaos für die anwohner
ja das ist eine wichtige straße für
krankenwagen für schulkinder ja auf
beiden seiten der brücke gibt schulen
und kindergärten ja die sind alle nur
noch einen großen großen umwegen zu
erreichen das irre die brücke steht auf
moerser grund und boden aber wichtig ist
sie nur für duisburg rheinhausen durch
die sperrung fehlt eine
hauptverkehrsachse in den stadtteil
hinein und wieder hinaus
die duisburger sind sauer dass ihre
stadt all die jahre nichts unternommen
hat es ist uns immer viel in die hand
versprochen worden und aber daran hat
sich nichts gehalten man kann sagen
beschissen auf deutsch gesagt es wird
einfach nichts gemacht er werde der eine
steht das auf dem andern die stadt moers
hat kein großes interesse und die stadt
duisburg ist sich keiner schuld bewusst
man verweist auf die schwierige lage an
der stadtgrenze
jetzt läuft einen
gebietsänderungsvertrag durch welches
die verschiebung der gemeinsamen
stadtgrenze erfolgen soll damit
einhergehend würde die brücke in die
baulast der stadt duisburg übergehen
duisburg übernimmt jetzt endlich die
verantwortung viel viel zu spät denn die
brücke ist schon seit vier langen jahren
dicht jeder schiebt es immer auf den
anderen dann wird immer gesagt dass in
zwei städte daran beteiligt das
interessiert mich als unternehmer und
als bürgerin einen feuchten kekse sind
ausflüchte die sind nicht
nachvollziehbar und da bin ich also
total enttäuscht und ein ende ist noch
nicht in sicht die stadt duisburg hat
noch nicht einmal pläne für eine neue
brücke und so wird die geduld der
anwohner wohl noch etliche jahre
strapaziert werden